it's time to talk with our friend monica
jackson monica good morning to you hey
good morning guys y'all look so pretty
and you're black and silver we are ready
y'all like ken and barbie this morning
we're just trying to be as stylish as
you monica oh well god bless you my
friend thank you thank you so much all
right kids hey this is so much fun and
i'm pumped to bring this to you it's
called positively arts and it's a
non-profit in the valley that helps kids
build confidence through the theater now
in today's mondays with monica segment i
had the chance to interview the founder
who bridged the gap between students and
the strip
tell us first of all your background and
why you are like
majorly qualified to do this job
oh majorly well thank you yeah i'm like
a cat i have nine lives before the age
of 45. so let's see um
my dream as a kid was to be like my dad
and be a doctor so i was on that trek
pre-med
and then a little monkey wrench i got a
call from the mouse the rat disney
right after i graduated college and they
said would you like to come and be very
good friends with pocahontas and i said
yes didn't even think about it so i left
my dream of med school and i went to
sing for the mouse for about seven years
and it was just wonderful
entering the performing arts world but i
did i missed academia so
i actually went back for my masters and
i got a masters in education with a
focus on the arts and child development
and that degree brought me to las vegas
and i actually started at the public
education foundation here in las vegas
working directly with schools and it was
then that i realized that there was a
need for arts integration and more arts
programming here in the valley so
that's when i decided to start
positively arts i left left the public
ed foundation and created a program
that specifically dealt with
enriching arts programs here in the
valley for our students very good okay
let's get into it give us the details
about positively arts because i had
never heard about it i thought i'd
interviewed everybody in las vegas so
i'm anxious for parents teachers and you
know uh people who are organizers for
like boys town and and uh boys and girls
club these are people who really need to
know you exist so that they can plug
into what you're doing even you know our
teachers at ccsd
yes and thank you so much for
sharing about our organization because
we did start in 2014 is when we became a
501c3 charity so we're a local arts
non-profit and we use the arts to
empower kids for life and one way we do
that is we use arts therapy as a way to
heal students who are undergoing any
kind of physical social or emotional
trauma and we use the performing arts as
a way to empower and build confidence
and resilience in those kids very cool
and we were talking about the teachers
or the mentors that you have on board to
help these kids get through it this is
the part i absolutely love because
you're doing some things that are you
know tough for a lot of organizations to
really clamp down on it's hard to get
into those trenches tell everybody why
your mentors are so very unique
yeah well i feel like i had a secret
back door into this world because i came
here also as a performer i couldn't give
it up so even though i was working for
the public ed foundation i went ahead
and joined some equity shows here on the
strip so now i'm friends with all of the
headliners on the strip all the
performers on the strip and one day i
turned to my cast and i said hey guys
there's all these kids here in las vegas
and we're all these professionals and i
want to create a program that bridges
the gap between the professional
performers on the strip and the local
kids in the valley and i did just that
so all of the teachers at positively
arts are the professionals that you buy
tickets and pay hundreds of dollars to
see on the strip and your kid gets to
work with them for free if you can't
afford it because that's what we're all
about we provide opportunities
regardless of your ability to pay
and see that's the part i really love
you know we go to these shows and you
know everything about vegas you're the
performer you've been up and down the
las vegas strip everything is over the
top so when you see all that decadence
children tend to think you know i'll
never get that you know that's
untouchable the fact that you bring
these people in face to face up close
and personal with these kiddos i mean it
just warms my heart and i know for as a
parent i know other parents can relate
to that and teachers as well so what
kind of reactions do you get from uh the
kiddos
i love that you say i'm a parent as well
and yes even before i moved here yeah
they were untouchable they were the
stars on the strip so yeah now creating
a program where i don't want to make it
this untouchable thing because kids have
dreams to do what we're doing on this
job and i wanted to make that in
actuality and i wanted to empower these
kids and make them believe that they can
do anything not just in the performing
arts world but in every aspect of their
life because once you have that
confidence you can do anything and the
parents love it yes okay polita if
somebody wants to get their kid involved
if a parent needs to reach out to you or
a teacher needs to connect you because
again you're you're dealing with kids
who've been through some sort of trauma
as well as mainstream kids so how do
they get in touch with you what is the
process
super simple go to our website
positivelyarts.org
if you click contact us you can contact
me directly you tell me what is your kid
passionate about what do they love to do
and we'll either connect them with a
private instructor to give private
lessons you can join our programming at
show creator studios whatever it is you
want to do we will make it happen for
you i love that okay how are you funded
i know this stuff isn't free so how are
you funded and how can we help you stay
funded oh my gosh thank you we do have
some outstanding supporters here in the
community the engelsted foundation bank
of america envy energy home lights
play studios and then a wonderful
individual donors as well if you just
want to go to the website there's a
floating support button you can click
right there and help these kids
actualize their dreams well let me tell
you i am excited because one of my
dreams came true today because i got to
interview a disney princess oh my
goodness
thank you i am interviewed by the queen
the princess and the queen together
i love it you are awesome my friend if
somebody wants to give you a call what's
the best phone number to reach out to
you you call me personally
407-928-7995 and i want to hear all
about your family your kids and how we
can build that confidence in your child
okay folks yeah and don't forget to
catch us we're going to do the replay on
the mlj facebook live show tonight at 7
pm